dos dramas venidos de israel y de
francia entran en la competencia del
festival de cannes 2021
el director nadav lapid entra por
primera vez en la competencia de cannes
con la rodilla de una cinta explosiva en
forma de declaración de amor y de odio a
su país israel
[Música]
tras su genial sinónimos ganador del oso
de oro en la berlinale nadaba prosigue
su crítica frontal a israel a través de
la rodilla de la historia de un director
de cine que prepara una película sobre
está mini una adolescente palestina
condenada a 8 años de prisión por haber
abofeteado a un soldado
y aprovecha la proyección de una de sus
películas en una región desértica para
verter toda su aversión política y
personal contra israel país al que acusa
de nacionalista racista y embrutecedor
de la sociedad
el prolífico director francés font show
son regresó a cannes con su última
película tu se habían pase un drama que
aborda el tema de la eutanasia pero
salpicado de humor de ironía
luto
la conocida actriz francesa sophie
marceau es la protagonista de este drama
tu sé bien pasé junto a andré dussollier
impecable en el rol de este padre
disminuido tras un abc quien le pide a
su hija ayudarlo a morir esta cinta es
la adaptación de la novela del mismo
nombre de manuel beriáin
por su abuso filmó con humanidad el
retrato de esta mujer rota por la
relación con su padre pero que debe
acompañarlo en su voluntad de morir en
un país francia donde la eutanasia sigue
siendo prohibida
es difícil respuesta china